entre les fermes maraîchères les lamas
et les moutons dans cette région bénie
des dieux
le nectar abondent plus d'une quinzaine
de vignobles assez pour vous désaltérer
alexandre morozov travail chez les
benjamines bridge 1 des vignobles les
plus prospères de la vallée d'annapolis
en 20 ans
l'expansion de l'entreprise a dépassé
toute attente on n'était pas préparés
l'idée car c'était fondé c'était un
petit domaine s'était limité à 5000
caisse on était là on allait être
expérimental on l'est toujours mais dans
le sens qu'on a déjà des styles qui sont
définies mais on n'était pas prêt pour
un influent de tourisme on s'adapte
shibam enbridge la production est passé
de 5000 à 23000 caisses de vin par
annick une croissance à l'image de
l'industrie viticole de la
nouvelle-écosse la marque de commerce de
la région
vin blanc et jus
kimora fusent travail dans un vignoble
plus modeste ici on produit 4000 pièces
par année
mais ce n'est pas parce qu'on est petit
qu'on ne voit pas grand et là on voit
qu'on a gagné 1 médaille d'argent a
indiqué zhang ming 17 et en attend a
toujours les résultats des concours de
cette année
trois des vingt deux chez blue me dont
ont été décorés au concours dictera
londres un des plus importants de
l'industrie
les vins pétillants de la région élaboré
selon la méthode champenoise sont
confondus avec des champagnes dans des
dégustations à l aveugle pour nous ça
nous dit qu'on comptait vraiment sur la
piste on fait des choses qui au niveau
international
ils ce sont des vins que les personnels
on a une place dans le monde
si les vignes poussent aussi bien dans
la vallée d'annapolis et grâce au
microclimat unique que créé en partie
les marées de la baie thuan si les
marées les hautes et les basses bouge
tellement d'eau et cette eau qui quand
elle bouge elle bouge l'air à laquelle
il ya un courant constant qui vient
d'assouplir un peu les températures plus
chaudes ici et les températures plus
fraîches un climat stable
créé par les plus fortes marées du monde
un environnement de croissance
idéal pour laisser mûrir les raisins
plus longtemps sans nécessairement
accumulé beaucoup de sucre parfait pour
des vins avec une belle acidité selon le
vigneron
ils viennent de l'école vraiment la cité
j'ai jamais vu là où j'ai travaillé en
argentine et en france on a toujours des
vins est beaucoup plus costaud mais mais
gardez cette acidité au fur et à mesure
que le raisin et mûri c'est beaucoup
plus difficile
l'essor de cette industrie a transformé
la région une 1000 personnes y
travaillent le double d'il ya dix ans et
l'industrie vise encore plus haut
extrêmement de spectateurs les
passionnés de vin c'est l'endroit où
être dans les prochaines années
super fiable je suis super fier d'eux
mais en fait travaillé dans l'équipe
koné a travaillé avec les raisins qu'on
travaille avec les producteurs qu'on a
pour faire des vins est vraiment il
cognait qu'ici on nouvelle écosse très
content et très fier et ça nous dit
qu'on fait quelque chose du banc
c'est le cas de le dire la valide à la
police est en pleine effervescence ici
elisa céret radio-canada dans la vallée
d'annapolis
[Musique]